- [Narrator] Thanks to Dashlane,
for keeping Legal Eagle in the air.
- I'm gonna make this pencil disappear.
Ta-da!
- Cute magic trick, also
first degree murder.
Hey Legal Eagles, it's time
to think like a lawyer.
Welcome back to Laws Broken
where an attorney destroys
your favorite childhood movies
by showing you how illegal everything is.
Because everything is illegal.
This week we're going to
examine The Dark Knight
and we're finally going
to answer the question,
can Batman use the
self-defense justification?
Can you trust me?
- Do you trust him?
- Of course you can trust
me, I'm an attorney.
As most people know, the
Batman stories take place
in the fictional city of Gotham,
but as everyone recognizes, Gotham is just
a stand in for New York
City and since I am licensed
to practice in the state of New York,
I'm going to be using New
York law for the most part
to talk about the various
crimes of the Joker and Batman.
So, be sure to subscribe and comment
in the form of an objection which I'll
either sustain or
overrule and stick around
until the end of the video
where I give a verdict for how long
the Joker and Batman
are both going to jail.
So, let's examine the evidence.
(tense music)
Alright so we have your standard,
garden-variety breaking and entering
and criminal trespass onto
the building of a bank.
- Three of a kind, let's do this.
- That's it, three guys?
- Two guys on the roof,
every guy gets a share,
five shares is plenty.
- Six shares, don't forget
the guy who planned the job.
- He thinks he can sit it out
and still take a slice.
I know why they call him the Joker.
- Okay, so these bad guys
have helpfully explained
that they are all engaged
in a criminal conspiracy
to rob a bank.
As members of a conspiracy, assuming
that the Pinkerton Doctrine applies,
all of the members of the
conspiracy including the Joker
are on the hook for all
of the criminal acts
of their co-conspirators.
So, I'm going to impute all
of the bank robbers bad acts
to the Joker himself.
(general shouting)
(woman screaming)
- [Clown] I said stay down there.
- That's funny, it didn't dial out to 911,
it was trying to reach a private number.
- Is there a problem?
- No, I'm done here.
- And that's just straight up murder
but because all of these bank robbers
are engaged in a conspiracy to conduct
an inherently dangerous
crime, that's armed robbery,
with guns, and bombs, and grenades,
all of those co-conspirators
are likely on the hook
for the murder of this person
under the felony murder rule.
But on top of that, the felony murder rule
would apply to any unintentional killings
that occur during the course
of this armed robbery as well.
- [Clown] Nobody make a
move, nobody, stay down!
(gunshot)
- Alright William Fichtner
bringing the heat.
(gunshot)
So, the bank manager comes
out with guns blazing.
You might assume that
this is attempted murder
because he's using a shotgun to try
and kill the bank robbers, but it's likely
that the justification of
self defense applies here
and excuses his actions.
We're gonna be talking a lot about
the justification of
self defense in a moment
but to give you a
preview, robbery is one of
the enumerated categories of situations
where you're allowed to use deadly force
to protect against it.
So, I think the bank manager
is probably justified
in using deadly force to protect against
the robbery of the Joker and his henchmen.
(machine gun firing)
And because the Joker is not justified
in using deadly force,
that's just plain old attempted murder.
- Boss told me when the guy was
done, I should take him out.
One less share, right.
- Funny, he told me something similar.
- What?
No, no, no!
- More murder.
- [Clown] I'm bettin' the
Joker told you to kill me
soon as we loaded the cash.
- No, no, no, no, I kill the bus driver.
- Bus driver?
What bus driver?
- Obviously this is
some type of murder here
but what's going on?
Well, the Joker knew that
bus was going to break
through the wall at a certain time.
So one might argue that
because he didn't intentionally
pull a trigger and shoot a gun,
that he's not liable
for first degree murder.
The problem is that because he knew
this was going to happen
and moved out of the way
and forced the guy into
the path of the bus,
that is a mental state we call knowingly
which generally carries with
it exactly the same kind
of penalty that you would
have when you intentionally
do an act that results in someone's death.
So, in this case, even
though the Joker didn't pull
the trigger, he knowingly engaged
in actions that would lead to the death
of his co-conspirator
which would qualify as
at least second degree murder,
if not first degree murder.
- That's a lot of money.
What happened to the rest of the guys?
(machine gun fires)
- And that's just your garden
variety form of murder.
- [Bank Manager] Look at you.
What do you believe in, huh?
What do you believe in?
- [Joker] I believe,
whatever doesn't kill you,
simply makes you stranger.
- So the Joker made physical
contact with the bank manager
there which technically
qualifies as assault
and because he used a smoke bomb instead
of an actual incendiary grenade,
I think that would probably qualify
as intentional infliction
of emotional distress,
even though the man was
not physically harmed
in the explosion from a grenade.
(glass shattering)
Destruction of property.
- Don't let me find you out here again.
- We're trying to help you.
- I don't need help!
- Not my diagnosis.
- What gives you the right?
What's the difference between you and me?
- Not much.
Is Batman justified in using self-defense
and patrolling the streets of Gotham?
Well, let's think like a lawyer.
(intense rock music)
The state of New York
recognizes self-defense
as a justification for
using physical force
in the defense of different people.
Whether it applies is complicated.
Now, the rules of using physical force
and deadly physical force are different.
Generally speaking, you're allowed
to use physical force in self defense
if you believe it is reasonably necessary
to defend yourself or
a third person against
the imminent use of
unlawful physical force.
Of course, there are exceptions to that.
You are not justified
in using physical force
when your conduct is the
one that provoked the actor
who is going to use
physical force against you.
You can't use physical force if you
were the initial aggressor
unless you have clearly
withdrawn from the
encounter and communicated
that you have withdrawn
and the second person
has continued to attack you.
Now, the rules of using
deadly force are even
more strict than using
just physical force.
You are not allowed to use deadly force
unless you reasonably believe
that the other aggressor
is in fact going to use
deadly force against you
and that is your option to prevent
it being used against yourself.
But even there, if you
have the opportunity
to avoid the situation
entirely and retreat to safety,
you have an obligation to do so
before engaging in deadly force.
However, you don't have a
duty to withdraw if you are,
one, in your own home
or two, you reasonably
believe that another person
is attempting to commit
a burglary or you believe that
the aggressive third party
who is bout to use deadly force is going
to commit a kidnapping, a forcible rape,
a forcible criminal sexual
assault, or a robbery.
Under those specific
enumerated situations,
you don't have a duty to retreat.
How do we deal with Batman?
I'm Batman.
Well, number one, I don't think Batman
is ever using regular physical force.
He has been trained as basically a ninja.
While he has a code that says
he shouldn't kill someone,
he has the kind of training that makes
his actions, I think,
deadly and, even though
he doesn't try to kill
people, I think it's clear
that people die when he gets involved.
We can disagree about whether
his acts are on balance
good for the city but
the fact of the matter is
they are illegal, at
least under New York law.
New York law does not
look kindly on vigilantes.
You can't just interject
yourself into crime
and pretend to be police.
It just doesn't work that way.
He would likely be on the hook as guilty
for all of the hundreds of
acts of physical assault
that he has committed again
the criminals of Gotham.
(slamming noise)
- [Joker] I'm gonna make
this pencil disappear.
Ta-da!
- Cute magic trick, also
first degree murder.
- Enough from the clown!
- (tuts smugly) Let's not
blow this out of proportion.
- Alright, threatening everyone
with a jacket full of grenades.
That's what we call a true threat.
Sometimes you run into
first amendment issues
and whether you're allowed to
say things to certain people.
That's clearly not allowed
here where you have
what are presumably real grenades
and threatening people with them.
- Why so serious?
- Alright, so there's some regular murder.
- [Joker] Now, our operation is small but
there is a lot of potential
for aggressive expansion
so which of you fine gentlemen
would like to join our team?
Oh, there's only one spot open right now
so we're gonna have tryouts.
- Arguably you could say
that those people engaged
in physical violence because
of the duress from the Joker
so I think the Joker's
probably on the hook
for two more counts of homicide.
(tense music)
I'm not sure what the
equivalent of the FAA would be
in Hong Kong but you're not allowed
to go gliding around a city like that.
That would be a violation
of airspace, at least
in New York City, I'm
assuming Hong Kong probably
has a similar thing.
So when people go base
jumping off of buildings,
totally illegal, reckless endangerment
and some sort of
violation of aviation law.
(shouting in foreign language)
And there Batman just
straight up kidnaps Lao,
whatever the Hong Kong
equivalent of kidnapping,
I think that's probably what
that man just engaged in.
(tense music)
Batman drops off Lao to Lieutenant Gordon.
So the question is, can the police
actually use evidence
that they get from Lao
because Batman illegally kidnapped him
from an international country?
Well, there is a doctrine that applies
to governments that says,
if the evidence is wrongfully obtained
and you use that wrongfully
obtained evidence
to find more evidence down the line,
that's called the fruit
of the poisonous tree
and often that is excluded at trial.
But the thing is, Batman
is not a police officer.
Batman is a private party.
So, while Batman may be liable
and almost certainly is liable for the use
of deadly force and
for illegal kidnapping,
the fruit of the poisonous
tree doctrine doesn't apply
because the police here were blameless.
- 'Cause they get anything on you
and those criminals are
back on the streets,
followed swiftly by you and me.
- Alright, another act
of murder by the Joker.
Killing the Batman-like vigilante.
- You see, this is how
crazy Batman's made Gotham.
You want order in Gotham,
the Batman must take off
his mask and turn himself in.
Oh, and every day he
doesn't, people will die.
Starting tonight, I'm a man of my word.
(maniacal laughter)
- Alright, so the Joker
there not only is he engaging
in assault and homicide against
this vigilante Batman wannabe,
but he's also engaging
in a terroristic threat
against the government
and people of Gotham itself.
Under New York penal code section 490,
a person is guilty of
terrorism when they intimidate
or coerce a civilian population, influence
the policy of a unit of
government by intimidation
or coercion, or affect the
conduct of a unit of government
by murder, assassination,
kidnapping, et cetera.
Here the Joker is engaging in all of that.
He's tryin' to get the
police to stop working.
He's trying to get Batman
to stop chasing him
and he is trying to terrorize
the entire civilian population
into disclosing the identity of Batman
and to turn against Batman.
So, I think that is a
classic case of terrorism,
of mass terror, and making
a terroristic threat.
(tense music)
Alright, murder of the judge.
Murder of the police chief.
(tense music)
- [Batman] They've come for him.
- [Joker] We made it.
- [Batman] Stay hidden.
- And technically, Bruce Wayne has engaged
in kidnapping of Harvey
Dent by taking Harvey Dent
away from the party against his will.
- Got a little fight in you, I like that.
- [Batman] Then you're gonna love me.
(grunting)
(shouting)
- Again, because Batman doesn't
have these justifications
of self defense, he is not legally allowed
to commit these acts
of assault and battery
even against the Joker's henchmen here.
He had a duty to withdraw.
Because he didn't, he's
likely guilty of several dozen
counts of battery.
- Drop the gun.
- Sure, you just take off your little mask
and show us all who you really are.
- Okay, here we have a
clear loitering violation
in addition to the normal things
that constitute loitering,
a person loiters
when he or she is masked or
disguised in an unnatural way
or attire and remains
or congregates in public
so clearly Batman is violating
the loitering statute here.
- Let her go.
- Very poor choice of words.
(tense music)
(woman screaming)
- I still don't fully understand
how Batman and Rachel survived that fall
but nonetheless, still an
attempted murder by the Joker.
And I think that probably
constitutes the unpermitted use
of indoor pyrotechnics or firearms which
is a class E felony in New York.
Even for the purposes of
wannabe detective work.
(glass shattering)
(tense music)
(grunting)
- And obviously Batman's
gonna beat the crap out of
some of these bodyguards, still counts
as breaking and entering.
Even though Lao's guards
are using deadly force
against Batman, that probably
doesn't give him justification
for him to use deadly force or close
to deadly force against them.
He has a duty to withdraw,
not breaking into the building
for the purpose of arresting these people.
- I want the Joker.
- From one professional to another,
if you're trying to scare
somebody, pick a better spot.
From this height, fall wouldn't kill me.
- I'm counting on it.
(male scream)
- Yeah, ouch.
- [Batman] Where is he?
- I don't know where he is.
- Alright, so obviously Batman is engaging
in assault and battery
against this mobster.
New York does not have a specific offense
called torture, that would
just simply fall under
the regular rubric of battery and assault
and it would simply be enhanced
based on all of the
factors that went into it,
Batman's ferocity with
which he beat the crap outta
this mobster for the
purpose of information.
California, on the other hand, does have
a specific crime called torture
which is found when an individual inflicts
great bodily injury with
the intent to cause cruel
or extreme pain for the
purposes of revenge,
extortion, persuasion, or sadism.
So, the end result here
would be, probably exactly
the same I just find it
particularly interesting
that one state has an actual
offense called torture
while New York does not.
(horns blaring)
- The hell was that?
(gunshots)
- Alright, using cars and
trucks as a deadly weapon
clearly qualifies as
aggravated vehicular assault
and attempted aggravated
vehicular homicide.
When you attack a police
officer, it almost always
enhances the crime which carries with it
a very, very severe penalty.
(whirring)
(explosions booming)
Alright, Batman is driving
his Batcycle around Gotham
destroying lots of different cars,
probably guilty of reckless
endangerment of property.
Someone who's guilty of reckless
endangerment of property
when they engage in reckless
conduct which creates
a substantial risk to damaging
the property of other people.
Here Batman is driving a
motorcycle which is not licensed,
which is in no way street legal
and is just destroying
cars left and right.
(phone trilling)
- Is that a phone?
(explosion booming)
- Alright, so, in addition
to all of the dozens
or so aggravated murders that the Joker
has just done by killing a
bunch of police officers,
he has also engaged in a
violation of section 195
of the penal code which is to
obstruct a government function
by use of a bomb.
There is a specific
provision that prevents you
from using or threatening to use
a bomb against the government.
It definitely applies there.
- [Joker] If Coleman Reese
isn't dead in 60 minutes,
then I blow up a hospital.
- So, in addition to aiding and abetting
the homicide of this person
who's going to demask batman,
it also probably qualifies
as criminal anarchy
and inciting to riot under section 240
of the New York penal code.
The Joker is just trying
to create pandemonium
and there are rules against
doing that, not surprisingly.
- Beautiful.
Unethical.
Dangerous.
You've turned every cell phone
in Gotham into a microphone.
- [Batman] And a high
frequency generator receiver.
- You took my sonar concept, and applied
it to every phone in the city.
With half the city feeding you sonar,
you can image all of Gotham.
This is wrong.
- Alright, Lucius Fox is 100% right
that everything Batman is
doing here is inappropriate,
constitutes a number of
different computer crimes
under section 156 of
the New York penal code
including the unauthorized
use of a computer,
computer trespass, computer tampering,
wiretapping, invasion of privacy.
There is really no end to how illegal
this particular tactic of Batman is.
Basically by hacking everyone's phones,
he just engaged in 30 million
different felony computer crimes.
- [Joker] At midnight, I blow you all up.
If, however, one of
you presses the button,
I'll let that boat live.
So, who's it gonna be.
Harvey Dent's most
wanted scumbag collection
or the sweet and innocent civilians?
You choose.
- Alright, so obviously
this probably constitutes
a number of attempted
homicides but I think it also
probably constitutes rioting
or incitement to riot
under section 240 of
the New York penal code.
(jazzy upbeat music)
Alright, that's The Dark knight.
Batman and the Joker giving each other
a run for their money in
terms of who can commit
the most number of crimes.
But now it's time for a verdict.
How long are they going to jail?
We'll start with the Joker.
There are a lot of crimes.
So many crimes.
Murder, murder, straight
up murder, murder.
I won't beat a dead
horse, but murder, murder.
- Why so serious?
- There's so many crimes
I'm going to have to combine
different crimes into buckets here.
In the assault bucket which
includes aggravated vehicular assault,
the Joker engaged in
approximately 65 counts,
each carrying a penalty of
three to 15 years in prison.
Given the violence and
severity of the crimes,
I'll assume that he would get
the maximum sentence for each
for a total of 975 years.
Now, given all the people on the ferries,
the Joker committed
approximately 400 counts
of attempted murder at 25 years each,
that's 10,000 years in jail.
Five counts of terrorism
and criminal anarchy
for 125 years in jail.
35 counts of first degree
felony and aggravated murder
for 35 life sentences.
So, if all of these
sentences ran concurrently,
the Joker would serve
approximately 35 life sentences
and 12,000 years in jail.
- I want my phone call
(clanking metal bars)
- Now let's talk about Batman.
Assuming self defense doesn't apply,
which it probably doesn't, and assuming
the sentences run
concurrently, Batman assaulted
approximately 50 henchmen, bodyguards
and regular people for
conservatively 150 years in jail.
Destruction of property,
kidnapping, and torture
for approximately 45 years in jail
and of course 30 million counts
of computer trespass and tampering
and wire tapping for roughly
60 million years in jail.
Huh, that is a long time in Arkham.
- You either die a hero
or you live long enough
to see yourself become the villain.
- I know Batman is supposed
to be the good guy,
but I was really creeped out
when he hacked everyone's phones.
- Unethical.
Dangerous.
- The people of Gotham really
could've used Dashlane,
Dashlane protects your
identity across the internet
by providing a tool that
generates strong passwords,
stores and autofills them
securely everywhere on
the internet, seamlessly
across all of your devices.
Even across laptops and
mobile devices running
different operating systems
and different browsers
so even Batman can't steal your password.
- I'm considering it.
- It's also a VPN which
acts as an intermediary
to make sure that all
of your internet traffic
is encrypted, even when
you're on public WiFi.
Try Dashlane free for 30
days at the link below.
Legal Eagles will get 10%
off of Dashlane premium
by using the promo code at checkout.
So, click on the link and prevent hacks
because the Batmans and Jokers
of the world are out there.
- You're garbage.
- Do you agree?
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist I put together
that includes all of my
other laws broken videos.
So, click on the playlist
and I'll see you in court.